let's go next to justin from
albany or albany new york uh i love both
pronunciations
i'm surprised uh as i i've never joined
a server before i was the first
i'm already called wow wow what's going
on
well i'm just uh curious i've been a
viewer for a while and it's just
uh with the right wing and this is a
complex issue so it's kind of hard to
like summarize it in
a couple of sentences but like i look at
like their attitude towards
lgbt people for example like transgender
youth what they were one of their big
targets and it's just like
do they do do we think that it's just do
people really just
not realize that they have an impact on
families directly who like
work hard just provide the best things
for their children do they are they
targeting those type of people
is it just a convenient tool for votes
or do they really
do they really think they're doing the
right thing i don't think there's one
answer
i think the motivations are different
for different right-wingers like for
example on on
generally speaking on lgbt issues there
are some right-wingers who have the
positions they have
because either for religious reasons or
or
whatever cultural reasons they are
scared of or believe that lgbt
individuals
are bad people or immoral or or satanic
or demonic or whatever there's that
group
there's also sort of more i don't know
if cynical's the right word but more
opportunistic right-wingers
who see these cultural issues as wedge
issues around which you can number one
get people fired up
and number two raise money and maybe
even win elections so i don't think
there's like one explanation
to be perfectly frank that's that's a
fair point
i just i just it's something that just
in my mind i just feel is kind of tragic
because they're just these are
real people like it's like trans youth
is like one of the big wedge issues it's
just
it just makes me sad because you know
it's just it's real people and real
families that get impacted by that which
is why
i'm passionate about that issue well you
know one good piece of news is
a study came out earlier this week a new
poll where
i guess for the first time in history
even a majority of republicans now think
gay marriage should be legal now of
course the battle lines have moved on
that issue because
gay marriage is legal nationally and it
has been for for years
it's more about you know religious
freedom to be homophobic
or trans but i i still think that the
numbers are slowly continuing to move in
the right direction
yeah that's what my friend told me which
is like i feel like most people in the
country are ready to move on from like
the gay marriage issue especially just
but
yeah six years later six years later
they're starting to move on from it that
tells you how slowly they move you know
yeah that's a fact well thanks david my
pleasure thank you for the call
uh some good calls we had that sort of
bad start with it with a dropped call
but so far it's it's going okay
let's go next to i bel is it pronounced
jate with a t from tallahassee florida
yes it is how are you good can you hear
me i can hear you fine
all right um i wanted to make a very
urgent comment okay in response to your
award-winning bonus show okay from about
two weeks ago
sure you were talking about going to a
thai restaurant
and then having some soup there right
and i have actually thai american
so i wanted to make a correction to the
pronunciation
excuse me let me guess is it my
pronunciation of
galangal no actually
in thai that herb is known as kah
calico yeah like
kha is the transliteration i think
wow but the actually i don't i don't
even know it was called
galangal in english but it was actually
the name of the soup and i think you
called it
tom yum but it's actually pronounced
wow well listen i stand corrected i
never purport to uh no thai
pronunciation
but the soup this is one of the i would
argue globally one of the best
soups and i would not want to disrespect
it with the wrong pronunciation so i do
appreciate the correction
yeah it's quite interesting because a
lot of americans call
pad thai or with like a p-u-t
as pad thai right so that's another
common one that's out there
well listen you don't have to know how
to pronounce it to love it i think
that's the upside for everybody
listening
yeah it's always a good question as to
when do you
correct pronunciation of food
in another language right kind of
interesting it's just
it's just if it's i guess if it's more
commonly had and known about then people
can
have the right pronunciation can you get
good again either
tom yum or tom yum in tallahassee
florida
actually i haven't looked for it i
haven't found it on
the menus here interesting at thai
restaurants
all right well i appreciate the call and
the correction
sure all right very good um let's go
next to a lot of corrections happening
which is fine i'm glad to be correct
corrected i want to do better